y millones de personas se vieron
obligadas a dejar sus hogares en un año
donde la consigna mundial era quedarse
en casa
según cifras de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados en 2020 hubo 82,4
millones de demandantes de asilo
refugiados y desplazados en todo el
mundo un 4% más que en 2019
richard wright sólo a pesar de la
pandemia que nos ha obligado a todos a
quedarnos en casa a encerrarnos y
confiarnos las tendencias globales de
desplazamiento forzado en 2020 fueron
más altas que en 2019 3 millones más de
personas 6 million people
la cifra no sólo aumentó sino que la
pandemia de kobe 19 hizo que los
desplazamientos fueran más peligrosos
borders admin se vive en la frontera se
cerraron con firmeza sin cruzar
fronteras especialmente para refugiados
no desplazados internos y no refugiados
salva sus vidas en light shading
la mayoría de refugiados y desplazados
parten de siria palestina y venezuela un
país que tiene a 49 millones de
habitantes fuera de sus fronteras
solo colombia alberga un cuarto de ellos
13 millones de venezolanos muchos de
ellos huyen de la pobreza uno de cada
tres niños venezolanos va a la cama con
hambre según cifras de la onu y las
donaciones internacionales han caído
también a raíz de la pandemia
acnur recuerda que hacen falta mil 440
millones de dólares para asistir a
migrantes y refugiados venezolanos por
ahora sólo se ha recaudado el 5%